britain has authorized another vaccine
for emergency use
one of the scientists who helped develop
the oxford astrazeneca vaccine calls it
a vaccine for the world it is likely to
be approved in the u.s sometime
next year charlie dagetta is in london
this morning
how is the news being received there
charlie david it has been hailed as a
vaccine
that will transform the fight against
covid a global game changer
and not a minute too soon in a country
and a world
under siege cheap easy to store in
transport and will vastly accelerate the
vaccination program
crucially regulators decided the first
dose provides
good immunity good enough to prevent
hospitalization
and serious disease a second dose
follows up to 12 weeks later
unlike other vaccines that need a 28-day
booster
that extended timeline allows for the
production of more vaccine
effectively doubling the number of
people who can get vaccinated in the
short term
the number that will be ready for next
week is in the
hundreds of thousands and then the
numbers
increase significantly after that the
urgency could not be greater
lines of ambulances with covid patients
inside have been
stacked up outside hospitals as britain
recorded its highest one-day
case total since the pandemic began
unlike the pfizer biontech vaccine
currently administered here
the oxford astrazeneca vaccine never
needs to be kept at deep freeze
temperatures
making it easier to administer in mass
vaccination centers
not just in the uk but eventually around
the globe
now the united states has put 1.2
billion dollars behind this vaccine in
exchange for at least 300 million doses
the question now is whether the fda
speeds up their own approval process
after the decisions made here adriana
charlie dagetta in london thank you